first off I want to know how do you guys
identify yourselves get Ronnie an
American Iranian just American Persian
Persian American how do you identify
depends of Brett TSA or not
hi I'm Yara in episode 1 of this series
I explored a slice of Iran in Los
Angeles
also known as Tehran jealous but now I
want to see how young Iranian Americans
are breaking down the stereotypes and
assumptions a lot of other people might
have about us there's a certain
stereotype about Iranian Americans
especially those in Los Angeles that
they're rich shallow and made for
reality TV but I personally don't relate
to those depictions at all I'm
definitely not flashy I mean I wear the
same pair of black pants every single
day but I do change my socks and many
young Iranian Americans don't relate to
these stereotypes either
like Alex chimps who grew up in LA he
showed me a side of the Iranian American
community here that you don't see on TV
and surprise he doesn't have any gold
chains or drive a white BMW we are in
downtown Los Angeles and the Jewelry
District so there are lots of gold shops
everywhere around us jewelry shops of
all kinds with a lot of uranium's
working around here Alex showed me how
tech Ranjha list extends far beyond its
symbolic Center in Westwood and into
Downtown LA's jewelry and garment
districts many Iranian merchants here in
the valley and many other places they
end up learning Spanish because most of
their clients for example are Spanish we
can just want to hear kind of like a
mixture of both like big on my begum a
Chen annihilated you know I found to
Iran Ian's who speak Spanish
cuantos anos tata botando accurate
intake
keep the onions mashallah what do people
misunderstand about the Iranian
community in LA I think there's a
certain image that many people outside
of Los Angeles have of Iranians
particularly because of shows like Shahs
of Sunset which show this kind of really
particular westwood rich Beverly Hills
LA Iranian that I think is definitely a
part of the community it's definitely
part of what's happening but it's so
much more diverse than that right both
in terms of the neighborhoods that
Iranians living across the city and the
kinds of jobs they're doing the kind of
lifestyles they have those reckon amma
CLE alex is right there are wealthy and
working-class erroneous secular and
religious irani ins Muslim Christian
Jewish Zoroastrian and bhai irani ins
just about every kind of Iranian you can
think of lives in LA including some
incredible artists and musicians
[Music]
[Applause]
sometimes I'll hear a melody and it'll
be a melody that needs voice but it
won't sound good in English so it needs
to have farsi words on it because the
Persian language is so sweet and and
melodic this is Chloe for Marathi
she's an Iranian American Jewish
musician who's never been to Iran but
she's fully in touch with her Iranian or
Persian identity I feel so so blessed to
have been brought up here because I
think this is the closest place outside
of Iran that you can get to Iran if you
want to really immerse yourself in
Persian culture we can do that very
easily in Los Angeles
people call me American but it's still
something in my heart that doesn't
resonate so much I feel in my heart
the Persian is first does your Jewish
faith incorporate itself into your music
spiritually it does I sometimes use text
from the Torah very beautiful very
poetic text much like you would find in
poetry of Rumi or Hafez or something
like this Chloe's music is unlike
anything I've ever heard
it's part persian-jewish Turkish Greek
and Balkan
[Music]
I remember I had a composition professor
he found out that I was both Iranian and
Jewish he was very startled he said
you're a Jewish I thought you were
Iranian not thinking that it's possible
to be both which it totally is the
Iranian Jewish community is a huge part
of the Tehran Julis story they've opened
restaurants playing this didn't come out
of a yeah that you don't mean the
supermarkets and even pharmacies and
that's just a small taste of how they've
shaped LA it was obvious to me the Shahs
of Sunset stereotype has really blown
out of proportion
but there's another stereotype that
young Iranian Americans also have to
grapple with that of the dangerous scary
middle Easterner biggest threat is now
Iran to talk about this I caught up with
Justin and Fossum MSU an Iranian
American couple who are also practicing
Muslims
oh yeah by the way so Justin
break-dances justin is half Iranian and
in 2007 who traveled to Iran to make a
documentary about breakdancing it was
his way of trying to bridge the gap
between Iran and the United States
coming back to the u.s. I was
interrogated at Homeland Security and
all of the footage that I had shot in
Iran was confiscated from me and I had
to do multiple extensive interviews with
the FBI in order to regain the footage
it was a huge kind of blow I think to my
own like sense of feeling and being an
American because it was always some was
like what the hell are you doing you're
treating me like a terrorist daily not
sure that Iranian Americans and other
Middle Easterners are marked as white by
the US government but a lot of us don't
agree with being labeled that way many
like Justin have grown up with constant
reminders that they are not white
especially after 9/11 and the war on
terror college applications job
applications Iranian Americans are
confronted with this question what race
are you even though I know I'm
technically supposed to check white no
I'm not going to my whole life I've just
always put other and then but you know
Iranian American even though people
would see me as like whatever you're
white just put the caucasian box I would
just I would always say I'm biracial in
the Iranian American community what is
it like being kind of I guess I can say
a devout or practicing Muslim I grew up
in a Muslim household where amidst my
cousins and aunts and uncles we were the
most Muslim of them so I constantly had
this struggle of figuring out like well
how Muslim do I want to be
well most Iran ian's have a Muslim
background those in LA are predominantly
secular so life as a practicing Muslim
here can sometimes be difficult if I'm
gonna wear hijab it really creates a
bind for me to be able to connect what
they run
for the first time with travel ban I
feel like irani ins are kind of coming
together and saying no as a people we
stand up and say this is wrong we named
him after he was born we decided for
such a teddy and it became very
important for us that just because he
can pass off as whites
because he is 3/4 Persian and because we
want him to identify as Muslim that his
name precedes all of that
[Music]
there was one more thing I had to do
while I was in LA get some amazing
Iranian food
Alex recommended a place called it's all
good House of kebab a restaurant you'd
only find in Tehran Julis just look at
the walls this is the only place in
America I've seen serve as faux honey
biryani it's kind of like a really
flavorful Iranian lamb burger with lots
of herbs and spices this is what happens
when you try to eat for a camera was
there ever a moment in your life when
you became more aware of your sort of
Iranian identity when the u.s. invaded
Iraq I was at a school where there were
actually no Iranians people would call
me Saddam Hussein Osama bin Laden the
halls like there's a difference between
an Iraqi and I find an Iranian or
anything else didn't really matter there
was a kind of hatred towards Muslims
start to look Muslim I very much wanted
to blend in I didn't want to look
different I mean obviously he had these
eyebrows and these facial features and
interestingly enough the mustache just
came out very quickly I should say here
developing quickly is a big theme with
Iran and I think the moment when you
realize there's something different
about you that's when your whiteness
suddenly falls apart here's the big
question
Persian or Iranian or Iranian American
or something else I prefer to identify
myself as Iranian and often I specify
uranium from Los Angeles because I
really do feel like the fact that I'm
from Los Angeles adds a certain
dimension to my randomness that for me
is like powerful like this combination
of people this diversity that exists in
Los Angeles I think has really shaped
how I think about being Iranian talking
to young Iranian Americans in LA I've
realized something despite all the
stereotypes and discrimination a lot of
us are actually embracing our Iranian
this it made me think about my own dual
identity as someone who didn't grow up
in Tehran Julis I wanted to talk to my
family about what they went through and
how that's helped me become my own
version of Iranian American
so we've given you a little taste of
LA's a riding community in the past two
episodes but the truth is there's little
pockets of tarantulas all over Southern
California in Glendale Irvine pals
birdies everywhere in the next episode
though we're heading back to Northern
California to interview my own parents
don't forget to subscribe for more
stories from untold America